und jetzt das heute journal
guten Abend das Realpolitik unter
anderem bedeutet blutige Hände zu
schütteln ist nicht neu da kam bisher
noch kein Bundeskanzler oder Kanzlerin
drumherum fragt sich halt immer wie
freundlich der Händedruck dann im
Einzelnen ausfallen muss das Center
schütteln heute mit dem saudischen
Kronprinzen war zweifellos besonders
unangenehm da ist es auch nur ein
schwacher Trost dass selbst US-Präsident
Joe Biden diesen Gang schon hinter sich
gebracht hat und der hatte in seinem
Wahlkampf sogar noch angekündigt den
Prinzen als Aussätzigen zu behandeln als
Energielieferant wird der Aussätzige
allerdings noch gebraucht vor allem
seitdem ein anderer Paare ja beschlossen
hat einen großkrieg in Europa
anzuzetteln Andrea Meuser berichtet das
sind die Bilder mit denen Saudi-Arabien
sich der Welt zeigen will junge
Unternehmerinnen erfolgreich und
selbstbestimmt Unterdrückung von Frauen
sieht anders aus so die Nachricht dass
aber kein nicht darüber hinwegtäuschen
für Kanzler Scholz ist es ein Besuch auf
Schwier teurer im Vorfeld hatte er
versprochen das Thema Menschenrecht in
aller Klarheit anzusprechen jetzt ist
die Antwort einsilbig wir haben alle
Fragen besprochen die sich um Tagen von
Bürger und Menschenrechten drehen das
gehört sich so und da können sie von
ausgehen dass nichts unbesprochen
geblieben ist Handschlag oder nicht das
war die Frage die über der Begegnung
zwischen dem saudischen Kronprinz
Mohammed bin Salman und Bundeskanzler
scholzlag es wurde ein Handschlag ein
freundlicher Scholz weiß er steht unter
Beobachtung denn auf der ersten Station
seiner zweitägigen ostreise begegnete er
dem Mann den der amerikanische
Geheimdienst für die Ermordung des
Journalisten jamaika-ogi verantwortlich
macht der den Krieg im Jemen befördert
und von dem Deutschland sich doch Hilfe
in der aktuellen Energiekrise verspricht
denn bei der Förderung von erdölstand
Saudi-Arabien im Jahr 2021 weltweit an
dritter Stelle die Vereinigten
Arabischen Emirate an siebter und Katar
an 15 beim Erdgas belegte Qatar Platz 5
Saudi-Arabien Platz 9 und die
Vereinigten Arabischen Emirate Platz 15
aber man braucht Kooperationspartner
insofern geht es um ein wichtiges
Projekt das nicht nur auf Deutschland
und Saudi-Arabien oder die anderen
Länder der arabischen Halbinsel
beschränkt ist sondern weltweit von
Bedeutung ist wenn wir eine große
Industrie etablieren die so wie das
heute mit Öl und Gast der Fall ist in
der Lage ist die Produktion von
Wasserstoff zu organisieren und sie dann
dorthin zu denen dann dorthin zu bringen
wo er gebraucht wird und so ist es auch
kein Wunder dass der Kanzler von einer
hochkarätigen Wirtschaftsdelegation
begleitet wird am Abend hat die
Delegation Saudi-Arabien verlassen
morgen früh stehen Treffen in den
Vereinigten Arabischen Emiraten auf dem
Programm jeder Schritt auf dieser Reise
ein Balanceakt zwischen pragmatischer
Annäherung und Wahrung moralischer
Standards
Andreas kühners begleitet den Kanzler
auf dieser Reise durch die Golfstaaten
Andreas fast vier Jahre lang war jetzt
kein Deutscher Regierungspolitiker in
Saudi-Arabien dafür das Gespräch heute
dann ja gleich deutlich länger gedauert
als ursprünglich anberaumt
ja einige Stunden länger der Kronprinz
Mohammed bin Salman so gefürchtet so
berüchtigt er ist hat heute gar nicht
mehr aufgehört charmant zu sein
gegenüber den Deutschen und sein
Königreich als investorenparadies
anzupreisen Saudi-Arabien will in 30
Jahren 30 Prozent der Weltenergie
liefern und zwar nicht mehr nur Öl
sondern auch als Solarstrom als grünen
Wasserstoff und natürlich muss sich eine
Industrienation wie Deutschland fragen
ob sie es sich überhaupt leisten kann da
nicht dabei zu sein aber es tut wirklich
weh zu sehen wie ein deutscher Kanzler
diesen Mann lächelnd die Hand gibt der
höchstwahrscheinlich für den Mord an
kaschocki verantwortlich ist der mit
Sicherheit für die Entführung des
libanesischen Regierungschefs Hariri
verantwortlich ist der für den Krieg im
Jemen verantwortlich ist und es tut auch
weh zu hören wie Scholz nach vier Jahren
den Namen kaschocki heute öffentlich gar
nicht in den Mund genommen hat ja
politik bedeutet auch blutige Hände zu
schütteln schütteln zu müssen aber es
ist ein dilem
morgen dann die nächsten Stationen
Emirate und Katar was was wird da
erwartet
auch da Begegnungen mit schwierigen
Monarchen mit dem Emir von Katar zum
Beispiel der ja auf der einen Seite als
großer terrorfinanzier gilt der aber
auch investiert ist in einige der
größten und angesehensten deutschen
Dax-Unternehmen es wird morgen um Gas
gehen um LNG um die Frage ob es stolz
gelingt einen größeren Liefervertrag mit
nach Hause zu bringen deutschland
braucht kurzfristig Gas Qatar möchte
aber langfristige Verträge abschließen
der wird jetzt hier im Moment noch viel
verhandelt als noch viel Bewegung und
entweder gibt es morgen eine große gute
Nachricht oder es gibt morgen nichts
Konkretes und daran ja wird diese Weise
dann gemessen werden und du wirst das
für zweiter beobachten Dankeschön
Andreas
es geht nicht nur um Öl Gas und
Wasserstoff Saudi-Arabien ist zum
Beispiel noch aus anderen Gründen ein
wichtiger Player nämlich unter anderem
als Gegengewicht zu Ira die saudiys sind
noch am ehesten in der Lage Teherans
Bestreben nach einer Vormachtstellung im
Nahen und Mittleren Osten einzudämmen
im Moment sind die Mullahs aber vor
allem damit beschäftigt ihre Macht nach
innen abzusichern und die Protestwelle
niederzuschlagen die nun den neunten Tag
in Folge über das ganze Land zieht
Glückwunsch berichtet
im Basar in Teheran konnte man heute den
Eindruck gewinnen alles laufen normal
fast jedenfalls denn vor den Türen stand
überall bewaffnete Polizei jeder
versucht das zu filmen würde aber im
Gefängnis Enden gestern Abend
protestierten erneut Tausende in Teheran
und anderen iranischen Städten gegen das
Regime trotz der brutalen Repression der
Sicherheitskräfte die sprechöre raus mit
den Klerikern Tod dem Diktator machen
klar dass die Geduld dieser Iranerinnen
und Iraner mit dem unterdrückungsregime
erschöpft ist in der kurdischen Stadt
osnaville nordwestlich von Teheran
zündeten Demonstranten offenbar auch
Gebäude der revolutionsgarten an in
sozialen Netzwerken sind Videos zu sehen
die Sicherheitskräfte beim Abfeuern
scharfer Munition zeigen von 35 Toten
spricht der Staatsfernsehen
Menschenrechtsaktivisten von mehr als 50
unabhängig überprüfen lässt sich das
nicht die Behörden haben praktisch eine
Nachrichtensperre verhängt das Internet
größtenteil abgeschaltet Innenminister
fahidi Hardliner und Ex-General kündigte
noch härtere Maßnahmen an
die Unruhestifter sind schuld an dieser
Internetsperre und wir werden die Sperre
erst aufheben wenn die Unruhen beendet
sind
jeder der jetzt noch an Protesten
Teilnehmer werde strafrechtlich verfolgt
so die Ankündigung das Regime setzt wie
in der Vergangenheit auf Einschüchterung
Gewalt und Schuldzuweisung an angebliche
ausländische Verschwörer vor dem
Foltergefängnis Evin in Teheran warteten
heute aufgebrachte Angehörige auf
Nachrichten von vielen Festgenommenen
meist vergeblich
Staatspräsident reisi lobte unterdessen
zurück aus New York seinen angeblich
erfolgreichen Auftritt vor der
UN-Generalversammlung
unsere Feinde wollen die Stimme Irans in
der Welt zum Schweigen bringen das haben
wir in New York erfolgreich verhindert
kein Wort dazu wie sein Regime gerade
die Stimmen der eigenen Bevölkerung
brutal niederknüppelt stattdessen ließ
der Präsident propaganda-bilder von
einem Besuch ausgerechnet in einer
Mädchenschule heute in Teheran
verbreiten zum Beginn des neuen
Schuljahres alle SchülerInnen trugen
korrekte Kopftücher sehr zum gefallen
der männlichen Machthaber die
Sittenpolizei musste hier heute keine
Mädchen gewaltsam umerziehen
und mit Blick auf Russland und seinen
Krieg gegen die Ukraine macht Heinz Wolf
jetzt weiter während die russischen
Behörden damit begonnen haben
Reservisten einzuziehen hat Präsident
Putin heute ein Gesetz unterschrieben
dass die Strafen für Soldaten verschärft
die dieser Tieren oder kapitulieren in
den drohen jetzt bis zu zehn Jahre Haft
die Proteste in Russland gegen die
Teilmobilmachung halten an landesweit
soll es nach Angaben einer
Menschenrechtsorganisation etwa 700
Festnahmen gegeben haben derweil hat der
russische Außenminister lawrov bei einer
Rede in der UN-Vollversammlung Kritik an
den sogenannten Referenten in mehreren
besetzten ostukrainischen Gebieten
zurückgewiesen
Energiekrise und Inflation könnten auch
die innere Sicherheit in Deutschland
gefährden so steht es in einem internen
Papier des Bundeskriminalamts aus dem
der Tagesspiegel zitiert demnach
versuchten bestimmte Kreise die
derzeitige Krisenlage für sich zu nutzen
das BKA rechnet mit einer ähnlichen Lage
wie bei den Protesten gegen die
corona-maßnahmen
in Italien wird morgen ein neues
Parlament gewählt die besten Chancen auf
den Wahlsieg hat nach den Umfragen eine
rechtsallianz sie wird angeführt von
Georgia Meloni Parteichefin von fratelli
d'Italia zusammen mit der leger von
Matthäus Salvini und der vorzeitalia von
Silvio Berlusconi könnte es für die
Mehrheit der Parlamentssitze reichen
[Musik]
der Wirbelsturm Fiona der von der
Karibik nach Nordosten gezogen ist hat
jetzt entlang der Ostküste Kanadas mit
heftigen Regenfällen und Sturmfluten
Schäden angerichtet in einigen Gebieten
wurde der Notstand ausgerufen der Sturm
war am frühen Morgen mit
Windgeschwindigkeiten von bis zu knapp
150 Kilometer pro Stunde auf Land
getroffen
krisen können sich sehr unterschiedlich
auswirken je nachdem welche
Entscheidungen die privaten Verbraucher
treffen hat das dann natürlich auch
entsprechende Auswirkungen auf
Produzenten und Handeln in der
corona-krise zum Beispiel als
zwangsläufig Restaurantbesuche und
Reisen wegfielen profitierte die
Bio-Branche die Leute kochten mehr
selbst und waren bereit da dann auch für
Nachhaltigkeit und Qualität mehr Geld
auszugeben jetzt im Zuge der Inflation
ist der Trend genau gegenläufig er wird
trotzdem noch gereist aber bei
Bio-Produkten gespart zu seiner Santina
berichtet
wie schnell sich der Wind auch wieder
drehen kann er lebt gerade Thomas Wolf
mit seinen biologieverdienst in der
corona-zeit konnte mit seinen rund 120
Mitarbeitern den Umsatz um satte 30%
steigern doch davon sind sie nun weit
entfernt seit Februar sind mehr als 500
Kunden abgesprungen die sich vorher
jahrelang beliefern ließen wir haben 20%
Umsatzrückgang seit Februar und merken
das ganz deutlich
Situationen ist für uns sehr angespannt
das heißt wir mussten uns stand heute
schon von elf Mitarbeitern seitdem
trennen weil es einfach wirtschaftlich
nicht mehr durchzuhalten war
es ist die gesamte Bio-Branche die
gerade ihre erste schwere Krise erlebt
noch im letzten Jahr verbuchte sie mit
knapp sechs Milliarden Euro Umsatz ihr
bislang bestes Ergebnis doch egal ob
biologisch oder herkömmlich erzeugt nun
sinkt der Umsatz mit Lebensmitteln im
ersten Halbjahr um 2,4%. das Minus in
der Öko-Branche fällt nach Zahlen des
Marktforschungsinstituts GFK deutlich
höher aus liegt bei 4%
. es steht aber auch Bioprodukte sind in
der aktuellen Energiekrise weniger im
Preis gestiegen als konventionelle Ware
die Preise nähern sich an
das liegt auch daran dass Biobauern
beispielsweise keinen mineralischen
Stickstoffdünger Einsetzen der zum einen
überwiegend aus Russland importiert
wurde oder hier vor Ort mit Gas aus
Russland hergestellt wurde und dort an
dieser Preisdynamik auch entsprechend
mit dranhängt ein weiterer Grund ist
dass die Transportwege für Bio-Waren
kürzer sind da der Biohandel meist Wert
auf regionale Herkunft liegt doch klar
ist auch viele Verbraucher achten mehr
denn je auf den Preis für den Sie
einkaufen insgesamt die
Lebenshaltungskosten natürlich teurer
geworden sind dann merkt man an den
Strompreisen mag man dann den Gaspreisen
und dann versucht man es halt im
täglichen Einkauf auszugleichen ob ich
Bio kaufen
ich würde gerne kaufen aber das ist mir
zu teuer ich kaufe ein bisschen weniger
das stimmt das hat sich verändert aber
ich kaufe deswegen nicht anders
die meisten seien verunsichert diese
Erfahrung macht Uta Müller die seit 40
Jahren in Wiesbaden ihren Bioladen führt
auch sie musste wegen der gestiegenen
Kosten ihre Preise erhöhen um
durchschnittlich 9%
. also das ist bei einem Brötchen
schnell dann mal 30 bis 40 Cent manche
sagen dann auch ist aber teuer geworden
und viele aber sind einfach schon
woanders
kommen einfach gar nicht mehr rein
47 Hektar Land die will Thomas Wolf in
der Wetterau auch weiter ökologisch
Betreiben der Bio-Anbau sehr wichtig
nicht zuletzt um der Klimakatastrophe
etwas entgegenzusetzen
wir kommen zu den Lottozahlen dieses
samstags sie lauten wie immer ohne
Gewähr 610 12 13 15 41 Superzahl 5
weitere Gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto.zdf.de und im ZDF Text auf Seite
und jetzt die Wetteraussichten morgen im
Nordwesten sowie im Osten größere
sonnige Abschnitte sonst viele Wolken
und zeitweise Regen vereinzelt Gewitter
13 bis 19 Grad am Montag bei 12 bis 17
Grad im Nordwesten und Südosten Regen
dazwischen recht freundlich ab Dienstag
nass kühl und windig
und jetzt zum Schluss noch etwas fürs
Herz ein ganz großer Sportsmann dieser
Welt hat seine letzte Vorstellung
gegeben und man sah Männer weinen
Völkergruppe
Ellie Gouldings Abschiedslied für Roger
Federer falling for you in dich verliebt
große Gefühle in der Arena in London für
Federer und Doppelpartner Rafael Nadal
einer der größten im Tennis geht ein
Sympathieträger gefürchtet geschätzt
geliebt die Teams Europa und Rest der
Welt lassen den 20-maligen Grand Slam
Champion hochleben jetzt bin ich es war
ein wirklich schöner Tag ich habe den
Jungs hier gesagt dass ich glücklich bin
nicht traurig sportlich erleben tausende
von Zuschauern auch den ein oder anderen
magischen Federer Moment zwischen Netz
und Pfosten passt wirklich nur ein
Tennisball das Federer und nadalier
Doppel verloren haben Nebensache es war
eine perfekte reise ich würde alles
wieder genauso machen
mehrmals überwältigt ihn die Situation
unvergesslich die Momente danach mit
Fans Freunden Gegnern und mit den
wichtigsten Menschen seines Lebens
[Applaus]
tja und wenn auch dein härtester
Konkurrent weint weil du aufhörst das
ist schon auch sehr besonders
das war es von uns bis morgen auf
Wiedersehen
[Musik]